[Music]
what we're about to do here
is very nearly impossible
[Laughter]
we're going to make the best paper
airplane in the world and we need a lot
of tools to do that
way more than you would ever think you'd
ever need to make a paper airplane so
let's go through the list here you're
going to need a roll of tape that's
25 millimeters wide and you're going to
cut off a 30 millimeter chunk and i have
a handy dandy little gauge here
that i've made for just that purpose
it's 30 millimeters from this edge
to this line right here and i just have
a little tab i can hang on to it
when i'm cutting the tape so tape
that's 25 millimeters wide you're gonna
make yourself a little gauge to measure
30 millimeters so you don't have to use
this clunky thing
a ruler you need a pair of scissors you
need a protractor
you need a snack clip the defining uh
part of the snack clipper it's just like
popped apart
my snack clip popped apart it's never
done that before
so we can get the jaws of death back
together here
is it is it gonna live
wow okay so this this clip
ends up being not not rescuable it was
it was broken right right this this
little guy right here that holds the
spring in
or holds the other part of it and it's
uh it's gone
gone okay so we had to go to a backup
clip situation
they did not have a padded clip
at my local market so i had to put some
padding on there this is
a snack clip with a sharp plastic edge
and i put some electrical tape about
three layers
of electrical tape on there to make the
uh to make it soft
on the paper so that's going to be
important later so you got the tape
we've got a measuring thing here sharp
pair of scissors
really sharp pair of scissors really
necessary protractor to cut
to measure these two angles here you
want 155 on one side of a piece of
cardboard 165 on another
you don't have to use the same piece of
cardboard you could have two chunks but
i thought
hey as long as you've got a chunky
muzzle we'll just use both sides of it
the other thing you'll need is a oh look
there's the plastic piece that fell
off that clip you'll need an exacto
blade
and i use that to transfer the tape from
the scissors
to the plane once you get a really thin
strip of tape cut you'll need a way to
transfer it
now i'm using a creasing tool here a
folding tool
these are widely available you can get
them at hobby shops you get
all kinds of uh places on the web amazon
has them
you'll want one that is um made from
something besides plastic plastic
is not great this is i think this is
made from bone
if you have an objection to bone just go
ahead and get a plastic one
but this this is a really hard chunk
it's not gonna
sometimes with the plastic ones you'll
get a groove going
on one end of the other you know if you
bang it into a table or something it's
just really easy to score and that
that just transfers right to your plane
and last lastly you'll need
a ruler uh just to construct your your
tape
gauge um you can double check the
measurements on the strips of tape but
that's really overkill you don't need to
do that
so tape scissors protractor
snack clip a gauge that you're going to
make using the ruler
and the pair of scissors you're going to
make a little gauge for yourself
transferring tool
folding creasing tool and then you'll
construct of course
you know this two angle gauge 165 down
here 155 here
that's going to be used to set the
dihedral angle so here we go let's clear
this out of the way
i also by the way just so i can allows
me to see the tape better i have
a fabric covered piece of cardboard here
with uh this is just some cloth over
it's black cloth that just helps me see
the tape better when i'm making cuts
so let's get all of this out of the way
boom shazam we've got
uh all of that cleared i'm going to zoom
out just a little tiny bit here
so you can see this is a4 paper on the
right it's
taller than us letter size on the left
uh guinness rules allow a4 paper
so that's difficult to get in the united
states but what you can do
is take a piece of ui slider size and
cut
a 19 millimeter strip off of one side
and now you have the correct ratio and
that's what we're going to use today
is a a4 ratio piece of paper
so that we don't have to go run out and
buy some a4 paper which is really
difficult to do in america if you're
overseas
you're in luck you can get it everywhere
in america we gotta make our own
okay so i'm putting the tape dispenser
on this black
piece right here just so it's just
easier for me to manipulate
um so the first step here is going to be
folding the plane and then we're going
to make the plane
work really nicely by putting the little
strips of tape on there so
step number one in folding the world
record plane i'm just going to move this
tape out of the way for now
just get that guy out of the way and
we're going to start by taking the
assuming just a touch so we're all on
that white there take the top edge and
put it against the sides
big diagonal fold we're going to make
diagonal folds each direction
my preferred method for diagonal fold is
of course to line up that corner
and then swing the edges together and
then i'm going to
sweep from the top to the bottom
and every crease you're going to see me
make today on this
plane i am going to really iron out
with this folding tool so
extra amount of time to use the folding
tool but it's totally worth it okay now
we're going to take this corner and
bring it down to this
into the crease you could practice your
diagonal fold technique by finding the
corner carefully
and lining up the edges and sweeping
from the top to the bottom
that would be one good way to do it now
you'll notice i'm creasing with my
thumbnail to really get the crease where
i want it
and then i'm bringing in the folding
tool and going over that thumbnail
crease so i'm really putting an emphasis
on
really sharp creases not just kind of
sharp creases
it's not amateur hour here we're getting
serious so now we're going to unfold
that
and the next move is to take this edge
and put it against the diagonal
we're going to do that in a special way
we're going to give just a little bit of
breathing room
between the edge of the paper and that
diagonal crease and the reason we're
going to do that
is to allow the paper to really lay flat
when it's folded
and so we're going to give ourselves
about a millimeter there all the way up
and this kind of makes this this crease
a little bit difficult to make you're
going to do a
one millimeter i'm going to show you
this can i zoom in and show you this guy
here
double check focus
it's just let me move it up even further
here can i focus there
so when you see that laying against the
crease there's just a millimeter
difference between where the crease is
and where the edge of the paper is
can you see that kind of sort of maybe
maybe right there yeah you can see the
crease and there's just a little gap
between the edge
of the paper and the crease and that's
going to allow
the uh the layers of paper to lay
really super flat and that's a big trick
to making a world record plane go the
distance
really really thin uh
wings then wings are always a must so in
this case
we're gonna take this corner over to the
end of this crease and we're gonna um
actually we're gonna let's unfold it and
do it i always when i'm doing the world
record playing you want
symmetry on both sides so we're gonna
move this layer over here now and just
give ourselves that same amount of gap
about a millimeter top to bottom
carefully put that into position before
we make the crease
see there's a way that in a second i'm
going to show you a way to check to make
sure that you've got
the same amount of gap on both sides
it's really kind of subtle here
iron out that crease and i usually
go ahead and flatten this part right
here so it'll help it even hold together
even more
so here's now this has not been opened
and shut so i'm going to open that up
and then shut that and then fold this
back over the top and then i'm going to
remake
my creases nice and sharp here all the
way around
and flatten out this crease that's on
top here
and if you look really closely there's a
little tiny square right here where
these layers meet
a little tiny square
and if you zoom way in you can see
we got a little tiny square right there
hold it this way you can see it where
the creases meet and the layer is just
short
let's see if you can see it here you
know we'll go up to this camera see if
you can see that's a little tiny square
yeah there's a little tiny square right
there where those creases meet and the
layers are just short
there we go you can kind of see it right
there and so
if if that's square then you've got the
same amount of
gap on both sides so if it's not square
you might want to reconsider
what you've got so far you might want to
start over with your bowling that little
that little square right there will tell
you that the wings are going to be
more symmetrical than they would be if
it's not square of course okay so the
next move is to fold straight down
across the middle of the x and take
pay attention that you're holding these
layers flat here as you
move this down and the crease is going
to go right through the center of the
action you're going to know you hit the
center of the x
when the top layer crease lines up with
the very bottom layer crease whoa what
are we going here
let's get this guy going
okay so let's go out here
so we're going to fold across the center
of the x here
the next move is to fold across the
center of the x you'll know you hit the
center of the x when the top layer
crease
lines up with the bottom layer crease on
both sides so take
real care to line that up and the reason
why you want to take care to line that
up
is because you're going to follow those
two creases so if they're not perfectly
lined up you're going to create some
error there so
get really sharp across there and now
we're going to
we're going to follow those two creases
as promised and i start by flexing this
one and letting go and flexing this one
and letting go
and the reason you want to do that is to
keep equal strain on both sides if i
were just to smash that over i would
chase some layers over this way
and then it would cause excess bubbling
so if i chase some layers this way
then chase some layers this way and then
bring them both down at the same time i
keep the stress on the plane
equal on both sides
and now i'm ready to make the center
crease on the plane and again
strategy for center crease on a plane uh
i like to do it as late as possible this
is the latest possible moment you can do
it
let's flip it over rotate the point to
the left
and i'm going to fold this guy in half
carefully watching how the rear corners
line up
and how the center lines up right at the
nose
and just gonna line up these corners
very carefully here
sweep back and then sweep forward and of
course
really press that down hard there you're
gonna just give the wings
a little
ironing out there too let's get this
center crease ironed out where all the
layers
are
everything is going to be flat here
keeping everything
nice and flat
okay ready to make the wings uh we're
gonna move
the i i don't know why i like doing this
side first i'm gonna flip it over so the
nose is pointed left
i like that side first i don't know why
i just do that side first
okay so things to watch out for don't
let this thing drift here don't let
these
layers drift here keep them i usually
use my thumbs to kind of
hold that in place as i start to roll it
over don't hit the nose don't go right
on the nose it'll probably happen that
you
won't once you start trying to line up
the tail but you'll see this
a triangle starting to form back here
you're going to keep going all the way
down until that triangle disappears
and that edge just touches that corner
and
sweep back and then carefully sweep
forward and it's a good thing that we
left some space at the nose so there's a
piece of tape that's going to wrap
around the nose
so that is good news there it doesn't
have to be that big but you definitely
want to leave you know a millimeter or
two
a couple of millimeters on the nose
let's see how we did here that layer
looks like it's staying together so
that's good
we're gonna flip it over and we're going
to do the other side
and i'm going to take care that my
crease starts
at the nose here the same place that the
other one does and then i'm going to
line up the rear corners
very carefully line up the rear corners
and sweep back
just gingerly sweep back and then adjust
the front of it
as best i can so it'll match there it's
all about controlling layers here
okay we've got
really nice sharp folds going there
looks like my rear corners came out
pretty good
flip it over and make this wing crease
nice and solid here
this is our one chance to really make a
nice wing crease i'm going to go ahead
and press the nose down
really solidly on both sides as well
right here
good time to do that
now we're going to do a preliminary set
of the dihedral angle
and we're going to use our gauge to do
that the first thing we're going to do
is hold on to it right here flex the
wings upward just a bit
and when you're looking down the barrel
here you can kind of see the the layers
change position right right about here
where the with the layers end
and so the first time i made this with
really really smooth paper i kind of
noticed that that layer was changing
there
and that was the beginning of the idea
to get the uh the dihedral angle the
variable dihedral angle so i'm
flattening the nose just a little bit
lifting this up in the middle just a
little bit and now i'll just double
check
i'm going to use my 165 degree angle
measurement
to look at the nose so it could go just
just
a skosh more right at the nose
that's really good it's measuring really
well right there 165
and then i'm going to use my 155 back
here in the middle of the wings
it looks like oh that's sitting in there
perfectly okay so the wings are right at
155.
let's just really make sure we're at 155
we're going to of course
double check and adjust at the end but
it's easier if you start this way
it accurately it's easier to get this
guy done okay so at this point i'm going
to move in
my black material with my tape
and it's a we won't need the gauge again
until much later
keep that guy handy keep our tape gauge
here we're going to pull this guy out
and we're going to
snip off with our scissors we're going
to snip off
30 millimeters worth of tape
so i'm going to 30 millimeters out
the tape gauge
there we go got the gauge right at the
end of the tape
i'm gonna cut straight across at 30
millimeters
there we go and now i just spin this guy
around and i use the back corner of my
tape dispenser
as my tape holding device i'm just going
to put that right there
and we'll put our gauge aside for just a
moment
let's get this so it doesn't look too
bad now you can kind of see the tape
over that white table there
that's looking pretty good i'm going to
move that around as i cut chunks off of
it so
you won't always have such a nice shot
of the tape dispenser in my piece there
so the first piece of tape we're going
to do is going to cover this seam right
here basically everywhere there's a seam
can you see that seam on that side you
can see it on this side baby
yeah so this seam right here that's the
first one we're going to do
and we're going to take a piece of tape
that's
about if you use the blades of the
scissors as about a one millimeter
adjustment this guy is going to be about
i'm going to spin this around this way
so i can see that edge a little cleaner
there we go you see how much i'm taking
there
i'm going to take about a millimeter
here right off of that side
carefully just cut down parallel with
that edge one millimeter
and put the scissors aside for a moment
i'm gonna attach that just to the very
tip of that exactly like that
and that's going to allow me to easily
put this guy in position here
i'm going to lay the plane on its side
for just a moment that's going to go in
i'm going to use that millimeter i'm
going to split the tape in half at the
same time
i'm putting a little bit on one side of
that seam a little bit on the other side
of the team
seam and then i'm rotating the plane and
wrapping it around
so that it it does the same thing on
this side so i've i've just covered that
seam
in a way that's going to hold that shut
and that is looking good
and the next move i'm going to do here
i'm going to cut a couple of pieces here
that are gonna go over this seam and
around the nose
so it's kind of tough to hold that
together
okay so i'm gonna cut just a tiny bit
wider
just to skosh more than one millimeter
that's a kind of a fat
seam that i'm covering so i'm gonna cut
a little bit more
and chasing the clip around so that
you're not covering the seam is always a
little bit of a challenge
so now we're covering this seam right
here
and this is kind of a weird one because
you're kind of going
the seam is more diagonal but your tape
is going to end up going more vertical
so you're kind of
splitting across that diagonal there and
you're wrapping it around and doing the
same thing on that side you really
it's not going parallel with the seam so
much as kind of across the seam in a
diagonal fashion
that'll help hold that one shut a bit
now the next move we're going to do here
is put a seam in the middle of the wings
and this is going to be a straight up
one millimeter cut
and we're going to cut this one in half
i'm just going to leave half of that on
the scissors for right now
flip this guy over like this i'm going
to move my clip
a little bit so i'm not in the way and
there is and we're going to start
this is where the point here comes in
handy
i'm going to put that right on top of
that seam here
and i'm going to put this out here at
the 30
millimeter mark which is you know
roughly the middle of the wing
just right on that wing seam right there
to hold that down burnish that one down
right now
you can see i got rid of that bubbling
right there let's spin this around so
it's a little easier to do the other one
again i'm going to leave my gauge out
here so i can see my 30 millimeter mark
there
i'm going to take this other half of the
strip that i just cut
carefully transfer that to the exacto
and then carefully put this in at the
same
whoops oh my tape deployed early so i'm
gonna
try to use the x-acto to pick it up i
didn't stick it down hard so maybe i can
pick it up there we go
i'm gonna reposition it on the exacto
whoa popped off now it's on my tie
this is definitely a non-cooperative
piece of tape here
all right you're going down buddy
right there all right
that is looking good the next thing
we're going to do is put this
seam of the tail together and this is a
seriously difficult
move here you're going to use a one
millimeter piece of tape
and the trick here
is that you're going to fold this tiny
strip of tape
so that it goes on both sides of the
tail so we're going to start
up at the top here where the wings meet
the tail
and we're gonna try to position it so we
can just see half
of that piece of tape and i gotta
there we go i'm just gonna pull that up
just a little bit there we go i got half
of it on that side half of it on that
side
i don't know if you can see that half on
one side let's see if i can
get in close enough so you can see yeah
so you can see
i've got half of that tape on one side
of that edge half of it on the other
i'm going to hold this together i'm
going to wrap it around so that it goes
all the way around
on both sides so this is really
super hard to do i'm making it look much
easier than it is
but it is very very difficult to get
that
to do that let's see let's get this
so you can see it's i've wrapped around
wrapped right around that so i'm going
to do the same thing i'm just going to
add one more piece below so that tail
all holds together
nicely again one millimeter cut transfer
to the exacto
lean this guy over see are we in focus
here not at all
and
and there we've got you can see it a
little bit more clearly on this one i
hope
that i've got
see that okay get it
it's tough to photograph here
okay you can kind of see it kind of see
it there
it's sticking out i've got half of it
adhered to this side and i'm just going
to wrap it around
so there's half of that strip on one
side half of it on this side
it's a tough move that'll take us some
practice to be able to do that
it's very very difficult
but you need to do it to close up that
tail now that tail is one solid piece
back there
really nicely closed
okay so um
next trick is we're gonna put a piece
right across
this part right here and that just takes
a really small piece
and so we're going to cut a piece to use
for that and we're also going to use it
out toward the wing tips to hold
the rest of that wing layer down so
one millimeter strip i'm going to start
by just snipping off
maybe three millimeters or so so i got a
lot of strip left there
i'm gonna leave that hanging on the
scissors and i transfer this tiny little
strip here
you can see how small that is
it's that size
and i'm just going to put that straight
across this seam
right here i'm going to pinch that
together hold it together
and use that to just lock together
my folding tool here i'm gonna
just burnish that down now that one of
the big tricks
with getting this plane to go the
distance is that these two
layers the right wing and the left wing
have to meet the tail in such a way that
that's just one continuous sheet of
paper so
this little piece of tape helps if
you're a tiny bit off you can kind of
cheat it
you can kind of cheat it flat a little
bit here but this this right here needs
to be just one
feel like one layer if you're feeling
across there you shouldn't feel a bump
as you move your finger across there at
all
it should just be one solid strip okay
i'm going to zoom back out here
we're getting ready to to now do this
tape
leftover strip we're going to put right
out here at the wingtips
so i'm going to take this chunk that we
shaved a little bit off of
my hair got stuck there and we're going
to cut it in half
and half of it's going to go on one wing
here and half of it's going to go on the
other
so let's make sure we're in focus here
we are
not anywhere near focus there we go all
right
so one strip is going to go on this wing
positioning your tape on the x-acto is
always a bit of a problem
your transfer is going to happen at a
different angle than you want
okay there we go we're at that wing tip
burnish that down let's do the other
wing tip
a lot of particulate matter in the air
today i kind of get the sniffles here
just a little bit
i'm sniffling and snuffling my way
through the plane here
so you're always orienting the the tape
so that it's
parallel with the seam and you're just
splitting it one side of the tape on one
side of the seam one side of the tape on
the other side of the t
seam now we have a little bit of
bubbling here
and if we have any tape left over at all
we could use it
to to burnish that down sometimes if i'm
throwing in
really variable humidity
i'll put an extra piece there if i can
muster it
okay so this next piece we're gonna cut
is a double wide piece
and we're gonna cut two millimeters
and it's gonna go
it's gonna get cut into three chunks
and the first chunk is going to go right
over the nose so we've got a double wide
two millimeter piece i'm just cutting
almost what's a square there
and i'm flipping this guy over i'm going
to move my clip back a little bit here
and this one i'm probably going to
transfer well let's do it with the
x-acto just just for fun here let's put
it on the x-acto
that way i'm going to wrap it right
around the nose here
are we in focus i've lifted it up so
we're not really focused there let's get
that going
all right so you're going to wrap this
guy right around the nose
pinch the nose together as tightly as
you can put it right across that seam
and wrap that around the nose like that
the other two pieces we're going to
close up this gap right here
and so we're going to take this piece
that's left over here
we're going to chop it in half
and this one i am going to apply with my
fingers because i want to be able to
hold this seam
shut as i'm putting it on there are we
in good focus there
kind of sorta all right so
kind of close to the nose just just in
back of where the wings attach to the
nose
hold that shut hold it really tight and
then
squeeze that around there i'm squeezing
together with my thumbnails
and i've really paid a nice tight
uh chunk right there okay so the next
thing we need to do is put that second
half of the tape on
and you can see it right there we're
just gonna go halfway between the tape
that we put on there and this seam right
here
so again i'm going to transfer to my
hand this time
and carefully put that right in there
wrap it around and really pinch it good
make sure that that seam is good right
there
so it looks like we have i've been
pretty judicious
with my taping scheme here so it looks
like i'll have enough to do the middle
of the wings here so i'm going to go
ahead and do that
nice fat chunk here for the middle of
those wings
to hold that down now it looks like i
have a lot of tape left over here
but you need a couple of really big
strips to go across the wings
or at the front across the wing so
don't uh don't think that we have extra
tape in any way shape or form
all right so so we're going right right
in the corner here is where we're going
with these guys no wonder i had a lot
left over
so it's i got a nice fat piece right
there i'm covering that seam right there
the inside
i might still have enough to do that
that little bulge in the wings we'll see
i cut my millimeters pretty thin there
so
what you're trying to do is cover this
junction between
where the wing is
meeting the body of the plane and then
there's another layer right here so
you're kind of bridging
this guy you're bridging this tiny layer
right here
and right here so the tape is in there
bridging this little corner right here
so it does take a fatter piece of tape
to do that
so push back out
focus up right there okay i'm going to
go ahead and try to do these little
bubbles right here
i don't have to cut a piece quite that
fat
so i'm going about a millimeter here
there we go
we're going to come up pretty nicely
with our two strips across the front and
cutting that in half
leave that behind
just going to get a little bonus chunk
in here for this little bubble that's
happening right here
so we're just going to cover that little
bubble right there about halfway
between the two strips that are already
there
so this is this is added this is not
strictly in the instructions
this is an added chunk making four
chunks
per wing which is one more than i
originally designed
really originally designed for three
this will help it go straight if you can
work out
so that you have enough tape to do this
your first time through you may have not
even enough tape to do the strips over
the front
it's really difficult it takes a lot of
practice to cut
your tape strips that thinly and get
them in place
so that you're happy with them okay so
uh we're going to do another measurement
here before we put this we're going to
cut this strip
into two pieces and we're going to put
it right across
here to hold the front of the plane
together but before we do that we're
going to do another quick
measurement uh using our gauge here
and just make sure that we're at 1 165
at the front
and 155 in the middle looks pretty close
looks really close okay so that's good
our initial adjustment has held so that
is good news
and so i always pull it off of the tape
dispenser to make this cut this is a
really hard cut
it's your last cut on the tape
and so
going across the front of the plane here
what you want to do is just far enough
back so that the whole strip is on the
plane
and just hold that in position the best
you can press down in the middle
real important to get it adhered all the
way across there
and then the next chunk is going to go
right behind it you're just going to
leave
like two widths of tape and put it right
back there in a similar position try to
line up the ends
and this this guy is really important in
holding the plane together
on because the plane will crash and the
wings will want to separate as the plane
crashes
into things and so it's really important
to get that guy held together nicely now
what you're going to want to do is go
all the way around the plane and burnish
down all of the pieces of tape all the
way around
so we've kind of started there you can
use the edge of a table let the wing
drip
drop off the edge of the table burnish
the back of the plane burnish this this
this
same thing on this side this this this
everywhere there's a piece of tape you
want to burnish it down that's good
now subtle adjusting you'll notice here
that this the wing is slightly
is curving just slightly from this wing
tip to the back of the plane
you want it just a really subtle curve
here this is going to be some of your up
elevator
and you can get some up elevator by
doing that
so that you don't have to add some back
here and it's a really sneaky
subtle way if you can get a little
concave curve going like that
from that corner to that corner and then
you're going to have to add a little bit
of up elevator right back here
but that's that's okay that's normal
you're going to want a little bit right
there
but start out like that with just a tiny
tiny bit of up elevator back there
and try this really subtle just a
slight bend right here that's going to
get you some
some up elevator without causing a lot
of drag and that's the whole taping
scheme
that's the world record plane always
start with a gentle throw
and work to a more uh you know
more energetic more thrust kind of a
throw so i want to do one other thing
here
i want to show you the difference
between an a4
sheet and the us letter size sheet so
there's a quite a bit of difference in
the size of the lifting surface there
you can see that
this plane happens to be the one that
went 236 feet 6 inches
and hit the other side of the hangar
this was the first time we tried this
really smooth
a4 paper so i just thought you'd like to
see the difference in the size of the
plane you're going to turn up with
and this is a really this a vintage is
one of my favorite planes the first time
on january 2nd
2012 the first time we hit the opposite
wall
of that hangar that we broke the world
record in on throw number one our first
series of uh throws right there
it's a great i love that plane it's all
beat up kind of now you can kind of see
it's all kind of ragged but yeah it's
nine years old
paper airplanes don't last that long
here is the world record plane
you can see just that subtle rake in the
dihedral angle from here to here
and that's going to allow the airflow to
change
as it goes it adheres further back and
it encounters higher dihedral angle
optimizing lift to drag
over different speeds changing its own
dihedral angle
effectively as the speed on the plane
changes you can see it almost disappears
when you look right down the barrel
that's what you want just really super
thin wings
re-crease everything burnish down the
tape and you've got a plane that'll go
200 feet even if it's made from just
26 pound paper this is 24 pound paper i
used for demonstration
you'll want 26 pound paper that's as
close to 100 gsm
as you can get in america or 100 gsm a4
the world record plane thanks for
watching
[Music]
you